[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the wheel of time episodes one
through three that are now on amazon
prime i'm gonna do more of a
on the surface review here and not go
too deep into the episodes i'm gonna
save that for when we do the week to
week starting next week with episode
four but i'm gonna give you just my
general thoughts here um i was really
really excited about this series now a
disclaimer i have not read any of the
books so with my reviews going for the
whole season including this video i
don't want any book spoilers in the
comments i don't want any mention of the
books let's keep it all to the show here
and save that for somewhere else so we
can all enjoy this like it's new i
really was blown away by the trailer
that they released for the show it got
me really excited because i had mixed
feelings hearing about the show and if
this is gonna be something amazon could
pull off and the trailer got me really
pumped so i definitely wanted to cover
this i'm a huge fan of rosamund pike
here and i feel like she's undercasted a
lot and i'm excited to kind of see her
in a big tv role like this what's
interesting about this show is it's the
showrunner is rafe jenkins who's
actually been on survivor which is
pretty cool because i actually watched
survivor and it's interesting because
there's a lot of writers here and a lot
of writers doing different episodes for
the show which can be interesting and
fascinating and i like that and that can
really work sometimes but what did scare
me a bit is in the end credits scene
that there's also staff writers which
can always be a little scary and that
maybe there was some rewrites here going
on but we'll see i don't want to over
judge that so it's so hard to judge a
fantasy show in its first episode always
because it's almost like work for the
viewer because there's a lot of people
you're meeting a lot of character
introductions and you got to learn the
rules of the world so you're kind of
judging on how clear it is and this was
okay in that department i felt like i
did have to do a lot of reading in the
synopsis of the episode to kind of catch
things again after i even watched it to
just make sure like wait this means that
and that means this it did good at
making clear of the rules of the world
and kind of what the tasks are here but
i did think it wasn't super clear enough
exactly why those were the five people
that the character of moraine was
targeting i know that yes they're the
reason being that it's possibly the
reincarnation of the dragon one of them
whether it's for good or for bad but why
it was those five what was about those
five so i thought that could have been a
little clear why they were those people
that were targeted i thought that it
could have been a little more focused
the first episode the pacing was a
little strange in the first episode that
did not continue for the rest of season
i thought we'll get into episode two but
i thought that had great pacing but
episode one felt a little kind of all
over the place a little messy i did like
this action-packed you know kind of
world of warcraft looking monsters here
it's like this trollux battle i think it
was cool that they didn't just do all
cgi i like that there was actually
people in costume here as a trolox they
kind of blend it so that was kind of a
breath of fresh air i love the moment
when the character of perrin
accidentally kills his wife that was
shocking because he's just in the middle
of this battle with these troll locks
and turns and kills the one he loves i
thought that was really cool and a nice
shocking moment i love rosamund pike
here as maureen i think she is awesome i
loved her big moment here with the
lightning crashing down her character is
just awesome and what i want to say i
love about rosamund pike in a show like
this is because what's great about her
acting and it's an underrated skill is
she is great with projection and i can
understand every single word she says
where a lot of times certain characters
you can kind of see the character matt
falls in that a bit here where they
mumble and it's important stuff being
said and you're like what did they say
and unless you have subtitles on it
could be a real chore so i think it's
such an underrated skill for actors even
though yes they're on tv they got to be
really in character but you still got to
project and you still got to be clear
for the audience to hear what you're
saying kind of like if you're on stage
but there's a way to do it with tv and i
think rosamund pike does that great and
she really shows it here in such an
important role where she's got a lot of
dialogue and what a relief it is to see
such a full cast of characters and
there's no bad acting here so you always
are worried that maybe one of the the
bunch isn't gonna be great and that
doesn't happen here so everyone was good
so that gives me hope that's the most
important thing i look for in a big cast
ensemble show like this so it didn't
hook me yet from the first episode but
it gave me hope and excitement okay like
where is this going to go it's so early
in the game especially a fantasy show
and you're still kind of going episode
by episode to really see how you feel
how you like it but for premiere i'm
giving it an 8.1 again i just thought
the pacing was kind of all over the
place maybe a little more focused i was
throwing a lot at you it could be a
little confusing but again still really
fun action sequence and there's no bad
actors here and i kind of like what
they're doing with the characters of
iguain and rand here in the beginning
it's a strong relationship and they're
both really good actors now episode two
shadows waiting was by far my favorite
episode of the three this got me really
excited i loved love the opening shot
here in sequence of when we meet this
white cloaked villain first and he's
burning this woman this powerful woman
it's same as moraine and it's an opening
shot here i love where it's like a
reflection in the goblet of her burning
and there's blood dripping i thought
that was awesome i also loved continuing
with this white cloaks group their tense
tense scene in the woods with our main
group here and rosamund pike having to
act like a normal person here and not a
powerful person in front of them it was
so tense and such a well done scene so
right away episode two it was more
focused we had the group together we
knew more already we were already
introduced to them so we can kind of see
what the show can kind of get in its
groove and it really did here and i
thought it was just a great tense
episode i also loved it was in the
trailer but it was also in the first
episode we saw a lot of them here is the
dark one he's like this voldemort
looking villain i think he looks great
and he's terrifying which is always
awesome to have in a villain so anytime
he's on screen i get excited so that's a
plus and the cinematography got to shine
here when they got to this abandoned
city i like it looked pretty cool it was
turning black and they were running away
from that another very tense scene and
you got to see the character of lan here
is just becoming more and more likable
by the episode the actors doing a good
job of showing that the music was pretty
good this episode was better than the
other two but overall the score of the
show again i'm a little disappointed in
it it's not standing out nothing's
catching me and giving me any feeling
just kind of seems in the background so
hopefully the score kind of picks up and
kind of gets more recognizable but this
episode had a great pace like i said it
you feel the adventure now in episode
two and again you know you have
characters you like here but i'm not
hooked yet i'm not so invested yet i i
find it enjoyable but i'm not there yet
at this point but this was the best
episode of the bunch i'm giving this one
an 8.7 and it gives me a lot of
excitement for what the show can kind of
hit as it's sealing now episode three a
place of safety was really disappointing
to me because when a streaming service
usually releases the first three
episodes in the show and episode three
is supposed to be the banger right it's
supposed to be the one that gets you
hooked and excited and wait ready for
next week because now we're gonna do one
episode a week besides the awesome
opening nightmare sequence perrin has of
these wolves eating his dead wife which
was horrifying and i loved and i love
they're not afraid to show gore in the
show i'm again a huge fan of gore but
also horror and not tone it down they're
really going for which i appreciate the
rest of the episode though was a slog
and i think that's also you know
something they're kind of biting the
bullet here that moraine gets injured so
that takes rosamund pike really out of
the end of episode two and all of
episode three right she's getting an
easy paycheck these two episodes doesn't
have a line she's just basically passed
out injured and it kind of hurts the
show because she's such a powerful force
in it and you kind of miss it you're
like why is this so slow and boring this
episode because i also think the pub
story was a bit too long here between
matt and rand and you know it's a
tribute i really am enjoying the
performance by rand i think his
character is really likable which is
good but i just thought it was too much
between the two of him and matt and
there was problems here with the
bartender i like the actress here and i
thought she did good with what she was
given but this bizarre moment how they
filmed it where when she turns on rand
you know she's like that door can't
break and then she just watches him
break it like with two attempts and just
stares and doesn't do anything and lets
him run that was really silly and took
me out of it and you see the show at
this point is three parties is cutting
between where you have moraine and land
together you have iguain and peron
together and matt and rand and really i
think they gave the boys here too much
time where we really need a little more
time with the gwen and perrin in this
episode and it just again i'm not
feeling invested in any of those three
stories totally yet and that's i think
what was born me and again because our
main lead here in rosamund pike really
just kind of takes a bad seat this
episode it's not a bad episode but
there's nothing memorable about it
there's nothing great about it and it's
really slow for a third episode that's
being released in its first week to try
to hook people so
yeah this episode i'm giving a 7.1 it
was disappointing and that kind of shows
you maybe the floor this show can go to
and how it can get to a low spot but
again not bad but we're seeing kind of a
mix of everything where i'd say episode
one was okay episode two was really good
episode three was just not great just
pretty bland so kind of got a mix of
everything so it kind of puts for the
first two episodes me in a place where
i'm like it's okay you know but it's a
lot of good i mean there's huge shots
here that look beautiful the
cinematography is really good and again
there's no bad actors which is always
good in a big cast like this that gives
me hope for sure it's not afraid to show
horror here we got a really strong lead
in rosamund pike but we also got some
newer actors here that are enjoyable and
hopefully they can just kind of get the
pacing a little better all together and
get it more consistent and kind of start
getting us hooked but again with fantasy
shows it's hard to really tell if you
like it or not you got to get to like
episode six so we can kind of feel that
out that's with every fantasy show i've
ever watched at least where i really got
to take it all in and process it and
again this has come from someone hasn't
read the books so i might get railed by
book fans but again we're trying to just
judge this as tv from this review and
that we're talking about it like tv down
below again no book spoilers please
please people let's keep this fresh and
give your theories on the wheel of time
without having read the books if you
want to give any theories i'd love to
hear them let me know what you thought i
read every comment i try to respond as
many as i can please make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss one of my
reviews of the wheel of time i'm
definitely doing every episode and like
i said starting next week because it's
only one episode i'll really go in depth
now every scene break it down for
episode four and all the episodes after
so you're not going to want to miss that
please follow me at steve barley show on
twitter instagram tick tock for more of
me i also do movie reviews and i also do
celebrity interviews and if you really
love what i do here i really appreciate
if you become a member today you get
perks and it will help me do this full
time one day and i really be grateful
and yeah i'll see you next time